questi ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono fa vj ed oggi siamo sul video
del texas quello ufficiale grazie a dio
ea ricominciare volevo darvi una breve
introduzione su che cosa ho fatto in
texas perché che cosa diavolo sei andata
fa in texas lo sai solo tu sono andate
in texas ragazzi perché milestone che la
casa produttrice del videogioco
valentino rossi the game che è il gioco
di valentino rossi non avreste mai detto
dal titolo mi ha invitato la tappa del
motogp in texas che si è tenuta la
settimana scorsa era appunto partecipare
al progetto del gioco che sta per uscire
che hanno fatto anche provare il gioco e
tutto quanto lo vedrete poi nei 2 pisa
perché faccio due episodi questo è il
primo perché ho fatto un sacco di roba
ragazzine che possiamo partire ci
vediamo dopo ben ali come di consueto
ragazzi blog dei viaggi iniziano con il
motore dell'aereo che ci deve stordire
l'anima oddio ma le giapponesi corrono
proprio come negli anime
c'è una proposta corsa incredibile ho io
rega vi giuro che al tipo di starbucks
gli ho detto che mi chiamavo lorenzo le
sembra scritto mi ha scritto peppo vado
vado farvi un viaggio con il mio amico
bene e poi si dovrà avere la cioccolata
calda prima che parta l'aereo
nel sangue
che cazzo fai
ha da poco in italia in questo momento
e quindi questo momento in italia ho 21
anni però qua in texas non farà 20 dei
ragazzi siamo arrivati all'hotel che
linton così diamo dei soldi a paris che
ne ha pochi lo si può sbocciare la zia
ma non lo so io prenderei delle
fettuccine alfredo alfredo nel senso che
le servono fredde ai capita spesso serve
alla madonna
come in ogni [ __ ] stanza d'albergo
ogni volta che ci arrivò proprio è ormai
diventata nella stanza proprio italiana
occupando paris hilton che voleva farmi
posso sapere istanza miei fratelli sono
senza una camera
sei scemo basta perché mi stai provando
le cose dalla valigia stiamo andando a
mangiare ad un sushi che si chiama
piranha killer suscitino veramente
parole come cazzo fai e chiamare un
sushi piranha killer sushi visto che non
ho ancora tecnicamente 21 anni ci hanno
portato l'acqua con la cannuccia alla
tua si sboccia acqua minerale se non
avete una candelina esatta il summit un
accendino carta auguri a te tanti auguri
che tanto non ti imbarazzi da diavoli
lorenzo tanti auguri a te mirino fatta
di soggiorno cellino
o è solo la goccia
ormai ci sarà ma muoio
bonjour cassoli bongiorno mentre
caricava i video mi sono trovato un uomo
che sta a cuore non vestito aver meno
quello sperimenti stiamo andando a
incontrare valentino adesso allora
l'ansia sul viso di lorenzo
sila la gara andata bene insomma com'è
andata la gara è andata bene mi sono
impegnato ci siamo per gli 8 gradi tutta
questa gente che qua per me
[Musica]
e poi
e anche questi signori ma adesso devo
andare a fare gli autografi e le persone
perché
il corso forte
adesso
perfetto
alla zia alla mamma alla cucina alla
nonna
alla ragazza caratterista scena che
figlia c'è valentino rossi che mi
abbraccia e mi chiede e io non dico
niente non dico niente è bellissimo e
ovvio che mi è piaciuto il gioco ma ero
talmente ipnotizzato dal fatto che c'era
lui che non sapevo più parlare è quali
sta invece spiegando che il gioco l'ho
provato perché michele risposta dopo un
ora il gioco è figo è che lui è un figo
e io sono i figli
attenti amico morti
adesso stiamo andando esattamente lì
sopra
e non è neanche carta la società serie
che moriamo la prova si deve andare lì
sopra per forza quello siamo seriamente
andando lì sopra non stavano scherzando
perché quanto cazzo è alto e una roba
incredibile
[Musica]
serio
è stato bello tutto a posto
ho preso questa cosa che si chiama si
chiama il pass o idea saluta mia mamma
mamma laura saluta la ballando amici di
fare una cosa la fa e questo è il bello
di cavo guarda tutti ragazzi venuti
non so perché salta dall'acqua con doo
parli è bellissimo leggi il mio futuro
lorenzo favi genito dove a parte le
cagate io non so che cosa sia non ne ho
idea
io comprerei il negozio non so se lo
sappiamo che voi tutte queste così nei
quali non puoi riprendere poi allora
addio fatto shopping e fatto shopping
come al solito guardato un sacco di roba
ma non ho comprato un calzino capito
mai
[Musica]
floro flores onore
no
[Musica]
[Applauso]
è nata andiamo a casa e niente ragazzi a
furia di girare siamo finiti sul
naviglio a milano tutto il leone da mori
persona cagate in mano pronunci però non
siete non si è visto però una generica
come hai fatto tu beh era non si è vista
posso chiedervi come mai un prezzo del
grosso come la mia faccia perché
perché è che la corda perché solo in
questo è la prima parte del video in
texas
nella seconda parte che uscirà più
avanti io ci sono c'è tutto il perché
voi non avete visto ancora niente c'è
tutta la parte anche dove sfido i
ragazzi della moto3 a valentino rossi
the game
quindi ragazzi per oggi concludo qui e
spero che vi sia piaciuto cosa influito
più il vostro documento è un mi piace al
capace di facebook e come hai visto
trascrizione cestistici diamo un posto
le ragazze